[Musik]
wenn du wissen willst wie der deutsche
tick hast aber nur eine woche zeit dann
bucher eine kreuzfahrt auf einem der
monströsen seelenverkäufer die aussehen
wie schwimmende plattenbauten aus
eisenhüttenstadt ist die kreuzfahrt
einst erfunden von adolf hitler als
schnupper einmarsch im freizeitdress
einfach schon mal unverbindlich gucken
wo man demnächst mit dem kecken grad an
land gehen kann
früher heute geht es eigentlich nur noch
ums fressen und damit die rosette
ordentlich zunder krieg fallen alle acht
mal am tag über das buffet wie
ausgehungerte piranhas über eine
verweste wasserleiche mit gelochten
deutschen an bord wäre die titanic auch
ohne eisberg gezogen und zwischen den
mahlzeiten gönnt sich die wohlstands
made unterdeckt ein animationsprogramm
aus der hölle
begrüßt von tv mumien aus der zeit als
wurm noch wände die nagelte herzlich
willkommen meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren my god und sascha hehn sie
auch schon mal gesünder aus deutsche
lieben kreuzfahrten nix selber planen
jedes urlaubserlebnis wird vorgekaut vom
schiff aus gesehen ist die welt genauso
schön wie im prospekt eingeborene
angucken ja mit ihnen sprechen um gottes
willen
man kann ihn ja zum abschied winken wir
fallen weg ihr bleibt hier nicht
flüchten
dieselben leute die zu hause mit der
faust vom balkon drohen sobald ein
diesel vorbeifährt findest total okay
dass ihr wohlstand panzerkreuzer so viel
dreck in die karibik trotz die fünf
millionen pkw
guten abend hätten sie vielleicht
interesse am captain's dinner ich nicht
aber der weiße hai
[Applaus]
[Musik]